after writing 30 pages of notes on this
show because i'm a crazy person i found
all sorts of weird clues and details
that are easy to miss upon first glance
i don't think there's been a show in
years that has given so much attention
to detail in every department from
costume and production design the music
and editing so this video is going to
focus on that and if you're looking for
a more analytical video be sure to check
out my severance ending explain if
there's something i missed in this video
it's probably in that one the very first
line of the entire season is who are you
who are you which is interesting because
the final episode is called the we we
are a play off the title of rooken's
book the you you are our first shot is
of helly and i just get coffin vibes by
this board room table the word hell is
referenced multiple times throughout the
season to refer to the lumen workplace
and even episode 1 is called good news
about hell pretty sure it's not actual
hell just more of a metaphor i found
this other shot here of helly's first
day which reads hello hell the show does
a brilliant job at extending this idea
of a severed work home life into every
aspect of the filmmaking process for
example check out this shot of the
parking lot when mark leaves work a
bunch of snow divides or severs the
parking space you'll notice a red car on
the top left and a blue one on the
bottom right with mark's neutral color
car in the middle just like him floating
between these two worlds the most
prevalent color dichotomy in the show is
between red and blue mark owns red and
blue fish his house is blue and herbs is
red the office is filled with red and
blue paper the envelope marks given by
pd is red cobell's office floor is blue
i could go on for another two minutes
listing all these differences but you
get the point in terms of what this
signifies i think it's used as a motif
to further show how this world is split
the red blue conjures images of the red
and blue pill from the matrix and alice
in wonderland in which one pill reveals
the true world while the other leaves
you in ignorant bliss kind of like how
our innies have no idea what happens in
the outside world and vice versa the
other color that's prevalent throughout
the season is green the office is
covered in it green is often used as a
color to represent sickness so a fitting
choice for our severed macro refinement
team green also happens to be one of two
colors in jane egan's first prototype
for the chip used in the severance
process the other color being blue blue
and green also happened to be the color
of helly's dress of the gala as well as
her earrings in episode 1 we learned
that miss casey also known as mark's
wife was an educator who taught russian
literature mark was a history professor
so it could be that they were colleagues
at the nearby college where mark worked
and that's where they fell in love it's
also kind of ironic that mark was a
history teacher yet spends much of the
season not remembering who he is the
majority of mark and casey's
interactions happen during quote-unquote
wellness meetings where two very
interesting objects are introduced one
is the red green candle that miss cobell
stole from mark's basement from a bin
labelled gemma's crafts gemma being the
real name of miss casey i think cobell
is secretly trying to see if this might
spark either of them recognizing the
other we also see mark mold out of clay
at tree the thing gemma supposedly
crashed her car into and died when mark
leaves work on helly's first day we see
her audi holding a bouquet of flowers in
episode 2 we'll see these are from seth
milchik in honor of her first day of
work miss cobell gives two contradictory
statements about her mother one in the
office where she tells mark that her
mother was an atheist and one in the
outside world where she tells mark that
her mother was a devout catholic there's
a lot of mystery surrounding cobell's
mother who is believed to be charlotte
cobell where we can see this hospital
tag with her name on it next to cobell's
cure shrine it's attached to a feeding
slash breathing tube and if you've seen
my ending explained video i go into more
detail on how cobell could be secretly
planning revenge on lumen for playing a
role in her mother's death in episode 2
there's an easy to miss shot of irving
looking at black paint in between his
nails it's later revealed that his audi
is a painter who specializes in only
painting that creepy black hallway an
elevator that only goes down the black
goo that irving sees is a manifestation
of this paint seeping into his office
life also in episode 2 we learn of a
woman who worked in macro data
refinement before pd her name is carol d
who we can also see on irving's employee
manifest in episode 9. many paintings
can be found throughout season 1
including keir's taming of the tempers
which is hung outside the wellness
office the tempers represent anger joy
fear and sadness and are manifest in
these four characters including a jester
and goat this is why there's a weird
dance performance by them after dylan
finishes his waffle party goats actually
appear many times throughout the season
especially in the background of devon
and rickon's home like here and here
pd's map of lumen also holds some
interesting areas that we haven't seen
yet like the coil of doom near the
perpetuity wing an area called team
building and a group of houses with the
line some people might live here
remember that pd said he found a
department where people can't leave i
think this is where miss casey has
always been in the perpetuity wing we
see how all the ceos of lumen are
members of the eagan family with keir
egan being the founder i think there's a
lot the writers can play with here and i
hope we get to meet more members of this
family especially this guy ambrose egan
who is mentioned as being the black
sheep of the family jane refers to
someone known as the grandfather and i
think he's referring to kier the name
cure derives from gaelic meaning the
dark one we'll later get a glimpse of
mark and irving's license plates which
are colored black and emblazoned with
the latin phrase remedium hominibus
which translates to a cure given to
mankind remember that lumen did start
off as a medical company in episode 3
miss casey says of irving's audi that he
likes the sound of radar which is the
name of his dog and later in episode 8
she tells mark in his wellness meeting
that she's only been up for combined 107
hours and that eight hours she spent
looking after hely was the longest she
hasn't been asleep to me this suggests
that her other self could be in some
sort of coma you may have noticed that
much of the lumens severed workspace is
empty almost as if they are expecting
more workers marx audi even remarks that
the company homes of which he lives in
one are relatively empty when combined
with james remark that he wants everyone
in the world to be chipped it leads me
to believe lumen will be expanding its
workforce but first they need to get
over some political hurdles hence helena
egan's connection to senator arteta the
name of the birthing retreat devin
attends is called damona who was a
goddess worshiped in gaul whose name
roughly translates to divine cow kind of
weird in episode 5 we see this painting
called the courtship of kier and imogen
who fell in love while working together
at an ether factory as you do with
helena being an egan and her innie
establishing a romantic connection with
her work partner mark i can't help but
see the parallels here the name of the
restaurant markets a gift card to is
pip's diner named after one of lumen's
past ceos when irving says goodbye to
hallie and mark before their big plan he
says the line okay kids
let's find out what's for dinner which
is what he was chastised for saying in
episode one hi kids what's for dinner
during the weird waffle dance dillon
uncovers this cat of nine tails whip the
same one keir holds in the painting of
the taming of the tempers each of the
tails represents one of keir's nine
virtues all those pitchers milkshake
took throughout the season were all part
of helena's publicity stunt to garner
favor for lumen and the severance
process you may have also noticed the
technology at lumen is pretty outdated
this serves many purposes for example it
makes it so that their work is protected
from conventional hacking methods and
this type of nostalgia may make the
workers more at ease with their office
life it also creates a stark
juxtaposition to the outside world which
has things like smartphones and is set
in and around 2020 as evidenced by
mark's driver's license the lumen
handbook we see in episode 2 can
actually be downloaded for free as part
of severnce's companion book the
lexington letters to which i'll leave a
link to in the description below for
achieving 100 on a particular file the
prize is a caricature and this one is of
dylan in a muscle show which he thinks
is audi competes in when mark walks
after his date with devin's doula
there's a sign in the background that
reads we sell severance compatible
attire which i think is just great
attention to detail this statue of cure
where two members of the whole mine
collective protest is in front of the
hall of records which is pretty ironic
since the whole act of severance is
about not remembering i love this
framing here where pd's head is
imprisoned reflecting his mental state
there are certain characters that wear
this lumen water drop pin these include
the secretary at the front of lumen
natalie the pr lady and miss casey do
they have something in common i.e never
leave lumen or is this just a
coincidence in episode 3 there's a sign
that clearly states not to sit on keir
egan's bed but dylan is explicitly told
to after his waffle party cobell's
bedroom looks almost like a prison drab
concrete walls minimally furnished with
a hospital-like bed her shrine has some
interesting bits of information like a
photo of what is likely her as a child
attending the myrtle eagan school for
girls perhaps this is where she wound up
after her mother passed in episode 6
mark goes on another date at a
restaurant called gerhart's another
eagan ceo in the security room we can
see there are dozens of severed workers
at least in this specific section of
lumen there could be other sections here
plus we know according to the lexington
letters that there are other lumen
branches that also engage in severance
i've also noticed that the state
abbreviation used throughout the season
is pe and i'm not american but as far as
i know there is no state with that
abbreviation it makes me wonder if we're
in some sort of alternate reality but
here is where i leave it to you i'm sure
i missed a bunch of stuff and if you
haven't seen my other ending explain
video be sure to check it out i've left
a link to it in the description below
thanks for watching everyone for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thingstoryt and until
next time remember
who are you
you